and I remember like every every guy was
going around and naming you know what I
mean the chick that they had a crush on
and then it got to me that's s and then
I named the girl I had a crush on who
was another staffer there and then
suddenly her voice goes on the
radio and I was like
[Music]
oh and welcome back to another amazing
and fantastic episode of the careful
boys where today we're going to be
talking about what is your f fondest
childhood
memory I have so many wow the fondest
one huh I think one of mine is um going
on like these road trips with my family
yeah like which is very interesting too
I remember my dad took us to San
Francisco When We Were Young Lads you
know and well I was young my sisters
were still like in high school or some
[__] but um I just remember him cuz he
grew up in San Francisco and he was just
he had so much and like showing us
around and like taking us to all these
different places and I never saw the
side of my my my dad before in a lot of
ways where he just was like oh yeah like
there's this he just was so excited he
opened up too yeah yeah and he just was
showing us around these places I
remember like us being together in like
the van and just driving around and
doing [__] I remember that was like
really cool and that was a moment that I
remember that like I think about a lot
randomly but until you asked that prompt
I was like oh yeah I guess that would be
a very fun
memory road trips are [__] awesome or
even just when I was a kid cuz we went
to go to Singapore a lot and just seeing
how my mom would just like take us
around and like show us like where she
grew up or where she went to go eat like
all those little things I think I really
um I will always remember that and just
think about it randomly throughout the
day you're quite the wander lust is that
what that means is that what it is
you're you have a Wanderlust type of
Personality what's that mean you
wander and lust for
it yeah I guess so I'm a very lustful
man you're a wand [__] you do a lot of
road trips yourself now with the kids
but but also too yeah that's something
that we want to do more of but um like
one of me and TI's favorite things to do
is to travel and like to just go see new
things together like that's probably one
of our favorite things to do and that's
always going to be something that like
we yearn for like oh I want to you know
like that's always part of our goals as
like a family and especially with the
kids now we just want to we want to go
explore things don't look away like that
dude stop doing that you got to be our
El Salvador tour guide yeah no like
doing [__] like that like that was tight
I love that that was so cool but I think
anytime we did things as a family
growing up cuz it was kind of rare but
when we all were Collective and like did
things like that I I think that was one
of our child the Fondest Memories no
it's it's sweet thanks dude kind of sad
that it was so rare yeah kind of like
you know yeah it was a little rare it
was a little rare like it only
happened handful of times yeah and gas
was so cheap back then too could have
happened more with the Ford windar dude
yeah driving around that thing
everything was cheap but yeah I guess
that's mine huh I think my funest
fondest memory is like summer camps
especially one where my grandparents
they actually like lived really close to
it and it had a lake with zipline blob
water slide w oh like you went to an
actual camp with a bunch of kids but
then you stayed with your grandparents
no we would stay in like dormitories and
stuff it was honestly like a killer
Campground they ropes courses obstacle
this is Ozark yeah no this is an
Illinois kind of close to St Louis I
always saw those in the movies and I
wanted to goe summer camps are the BBM
camps are the best that's why I wanted
to do uh Boy Scouts in nature for a week
with a bunch of like random kids that
you're all just having a time of your
life with yeah yeah damn I forgot about
how good that was cuz when you watch
that in movies you're like man I always
want to do that I often wonder why we
don't have some more CER adults like
just they should huh there are some
cancer adult like DMT Retreats yeah see
it becomes all weird though can be doing
those on it's got to be like religious
or something a summer camp counselor I
would if you really want to as a adult I
definitely have one to recommend we
should do it yeah butes it doesn't be
mushrooms though is it sandals or
whatever the [__] no hey but I want to
learn how to tie knots and do like
normal [__] like I'm not going in there
to like [__] go to boot camp or some
[__] why is it that you have one to
recommend you've been on an adult summer
camp yeah you know e thr one oh that's
what that is yeah it's a summer camp M I
didn't know that yeah oh wow adults yeah
what is um like uh e which is a
nonprofit uh group of of the homies like
K and stuff like that um they they throw
a summer camp cool I like that and it's
like that obviously there I mean I'm
sure that there are you know other party
fav do we get badges no it's not
necessarily like that you're not trying
to be a kid about it but but it is it is
kid like uh Wonder like a childlike
Wonder are bunk BS no you bring tents
and stuff like that oh okay that's fine
too yeah yeah but no it's really fun but
anyways summer camps awesome especially
should we do one dude let's do adult
summer camp JK new summer camp coming
soon JK summer camp only 100 people can
sign up oh dang or maybe just you know
us we're just the boys keep the
strangers out no girls
allowed no girls are allowed yeah girls
really I don't like that no girls you
rather have no girls okay I don't like
that only if they're strippers what damn
that kind stripper Camp coming soon
hosted by JK news like 25 strippers take
a trip to Lake Arrowhead that does
trigger a childhood memory of mine uh a
summer camp that I used to uh both
participated and become a staff member
of afterwards every single year was
through the America Red Cross it was
called LDC like leadership development
center I went there as a delegate like
uh just my first year and then you know
you meet people I met my first couple
girlfriends there um damn the the cool
part I just vividly remember this the
next year we would go back at staffers
before like the the delegates would come
in so we prepare stuff right and I
remember like the guy staffers would be
in one cabin and the girl staffers would
be in another and there would be like
some walkie-talkies and then would
walkie-talkie what you thought was the
guy's Channel and everybody at night you
know this is like when you're [__]
super adolescent everybody's like who do
you have a crush on it right and you
thought you was on the guy's Channel but
the obviously somehow the girls knew
which channel the guy's channel was and
I remember like every every guy was
going around and naming you know what I
mean the chick that they had a crush on
and then it got to me that's s and then
I named the girl I had a crush on who
was another staffer there and then
suddenly her voice goes on the radio
[__] and I was like oh [__] and it was
just a huge blow up but it was positive
feedback blow it wasn't like ew or
anything like that we ended up yeah but
then she broke my heart later so
whatever wait what dude yeah we got
together for like 2 months or whatever
but she broke her heart but just that
feeling in that moment those are
dope dope so much [__] dope me those
guys against girls moments are like
always like oh man [__] [__] great
broke Anthony these art but yeah that
was hell of fun I think one of my
favorite things was not knowing what was
going to happen after school and you're
just like what kind of [__] are we going
to do from Summer to just that whole
Elementary phase right where it's just
like your goal is like what kind of fun
[__] are we going to do today like it's
still that now but back then it was just
that that was the goal every day it's
like who am I going to go play with you
know and you're like maybe Frankie's
home and you come over hey you home all
right let's go get some [__] right whose
trampoline we jumping on I know like
it's like always something different do
you have a most fun one that comes to
mind right now I had um a neighbor
across the street her name was Christa
and she had a little brother Johnny and
across from there there was a boy named
Johnny and Adam and then we would all
get together like a bunch of Rugrats and
just their backyard was like a junkyard
so they just had hella cars and things
that we would pretend like we racing and
like sick yeah there was a lot of fun
[__] to do on that street and there was
a lot of kids cuz I lived around a
elementary school so it was like meeting
up with them and then like playing games
or whatever every single day I think
that [__] was hella fun yeah I know and
just going if we got bored with each
other or like we want to combine forces
with another neighborhood like there'll
be kids down the block and you just bike
all the way down and then like you just
get together and there's like 30 40 kids
so it's it's like oh yeah it got pretty
wild yeah dude that's a mob and our
school was open campus so like we live
next to an elementary school and like
you know like kids are getting picked up
till like you know way later from their
parents right so then we can go back
into the playground and play too so oh
that's cool I used to do that a lot as a
kid too live right next to Elementary
the playground came in
clutch that's nice to live that close
you know what a quick one is though is
lowkey after school you go to
Blockbuster bro oh yeah you know the
[__] the dopamine hits you would get
when you pick out a movie with the fam
you're just like we get to watch this or
you go to get a locco video spot and you
go to like the adults only curtain what
just keep it's all covered and you're
yeah you're just trying to get a PE like
I'm just curious what's over there dude
this is a picture of the of my memory
it's basically like oh what it's a
picture well like when you see it you'll
know what I'm talking about but um um we
used to go to this store called fedco
fedco dude the one that's on [__] uh
South and and that that was our main
like store that we would go to and as a
kid the pizza there is so good oh dude
yeah but the best thing was I would
always run to this exact section look
that what section is that that's where
the that's where the Nintendo games went
oh [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah that that so
it would always say world of Nintendo
and like it you I would just have the
same memory of just rushing over to it
as soon as we got in there and just
looking at games and just like that was
my Nirvana every time I would just be
like this is it this is all I want out
of life in California did you guys have
the game demos in Walmart where you
could like go and just like look up at
the screens above the gamees that was
that came later I think we were just
that at my time there was no demos you
can't play like you could just imagine
what the game is like or like there's a
game um Genie or like a magazine
Nintendo Power previews of the game so
you would look at it in the magazine you
could just imagine what the game is
going to be like yeah you had to really
just like or you just take the cashier's
word for it like my dad would do that he
would just ask them like what's the
hottest game what's everybody buying and
then they'll be like oh for some reason
everyone's buying this Ninja Turtles
game oh I don't know legit legit but
like just sitting there and just staring
at it every time that was like my
favorite thing to do bro as soon as you
said Ninja Turtles flashbacks to Pizza
Hut birthday parties with Ninja Turtle
games and Mortal Kombat and all that
stuff the arcade one yeah I used to live
next to a a Pog like baseball comic book
kind of shop right oh cool love those
shops and then they were also the they
had like Neo Geo Street Fighter all that
so all all the kids would just line up
and then you do the whole quarter thing
and like and just wait that's sick yeah
and I always used doam and I they
[__] hated me all my best
all my best kid memories are with with
games like especially when Street
Fighter first came out and that was like
everyone's playing it you go to like the
laundry mat and they had it there I
distinctly remember taking my bike to go
to the donut shop that had Street
Fighter 2 that was around the corner of
my house and you could never play it
because you know what the stereotypical
80s bad guy teen looks like they would
always be surrounding it and they would
just be like n kid no sleeves yeah they
would have no sleeves they would have a
thin bandana like tied they look like
Karate Kid bad guys and they were all
white which is like you never see gangs
like that anymore and they would just be
like sorry kid machines taken and I
would just have to stand there and watch
everyone else play cuz they were all
like older teams and I would be like
this is the greatest game on
earth sorry kid yeah they would always
block my way just be like no man we're
playing right now I didn't experience it
that much but I miss arcade culture like
yeah able to play video games like in
public with friends you he he was right
next to one every [__] day of his
life Wow first it was Western arcade
remember before it was nickel nickel did
you have unlimited quarters cuz you
worked at a laundromat uh no it was a
dry cleaner different I didn't know very
different different class okay we did a
compilation of all those laat they wash
their own clothes dry cleaners we wash
their clothes like servants okay it's
different I just thought you took it
from the coin laundry and you walked
across the street and you went to Nickel
Nickel yeah a kid me and my sister would
be small enough to go behind the
machines and try to like scoop quarters
up and we always get yelled at by the
manager but did your parents ever like
forbid you from going there ever I mean
cuz as a kid how could you just not want
to be there all the time I wanted to be
there all the time but at the same time
if you don't have money but see play the
game you also are torturing yourself you
know what I'm saying but uh but I was
there all the time oh [__] all the time
um there was also you remember the Razor
scooter yeah so I was the first kid on
my b Razor scooter right you were the
first kid yeah I've never been the first
at anything right how did you get the
memo to get one of those things so
here's the thing I have an uncle and and
my cousins in general um I talked about
pcking the lady before yeah that family
before they had pcking the lady they
owned toys and joys on aahu so they ran
basically one of the most like notorious
toy stores that animated all these games
he's the guy who gave me like Nintendo
Super Nintendo PlayStation everything
growing up my entire childhood was based
off of what I was being gifted from
these people cuz my parents could never
buy me anything and I just remember one
morning cuz when they come over and
visit every single time they came over
and visit they would take my room yeah
so I would have to sleep downstairs and
I remember sleeping downstairs with my
cousin I woke up it was a Christmas
morning I woke up and my eyes open and I
saw the box of a Razor scooter right
there and you knew what it was yeah
because I was I at that time for some
reason there was like commercials or
promos or something like they were
chilling at it was the hottest thing
ever probably on a Gogurt commercial
yeah and I [__] was the first kid on
my whole block in school that got it he
probably got Mega popular it was the OG
one with the green neon wheels just
aluminum did you show up to school like
paddling it like not on a school day
because we weren't allowed to but like
on an off day I just like scooted all
the way to school be the only one and
the coolest part is you pack it up you
throw over your shoulder dude that was
actually really heavy and I was really
small but so you're dragging it two
hands damn that Ted to be the first one
the Razer scooter taught me how to ride
a bike how's that oh just knowing
balance and stuff I couldn't ride a
[__] bike until I was 11 bro my 11 my
11th birthday my grandma bought me a
Razor scooter it was all red cuz you
know your boy and once I rode on that
thing I hopped on the bike and I could
ride a bike all of a sudden oh so I
think I'm a little dyslexic W weird all
of a sudden all of a sudden I'm glad you
guys didn't make fun of me for not being
able to ride a bikee tills
11 did you guys climb trees growing up
oh yeah I was too scared tree all dayar
I was too scared dude I was doing the
most wild stuff in trees like I was up
like 30 40 ft like you probably had
pretty good trees though where
you we had you had sick trees dude you
got like palm trees do you think when
you come out of California like these
trees you can't even climb these [__]
you have to climb it like
Mulan me and barart were just ch and
plants off bro that story I think about
all the time dude are the enemy of the
trees drive around Buena Park Cypress
toito those you'll see them just R out a
bike just [__] whack you'll see kids
chopping them oh my god did you grow up
in a big school like as a kid elementary
school did you meet new kids all the
time growing up kind of dude anytime
that like I was in a situation where
there was a field trip and you saw
another group of kids I would get so
hype because my whole class like growing
up my classes were always 12 to 13
people she went like a private school
yeah they were always really small yeah
really really small so every time like
we went to we would go to Ellie County
Fair every year I would always try to
meet random ass kids and so you're going
at makeing friends huh no but they would
be weirded out cuz they'd be like why
are you trying to talk to us or they
they' instantly like exclude me what was
your opening line I don't I don't know I
think I would just walk up and just say
hi and my name's Ryan like mad Regular
yeah because I just wanted to meet new
[__] kids for once the same do people
at church the same people at school so
like anywhere else we went we were like
yo what's up man Brave kid dude it's
probably why you became a dancer that's
why you became a dancer prob why you
became a dancer oh I mean cuz then you
could walk up to kids and be like look
at this look at I could be my friend
just get my ass kicked immediately yeah
R got jumped a lot that's true cuz when
I went to the same school when we went
yeah I thought that was so small it is
Tiny dude going from like public school
to that it's like wow but then I forgot
how like private school can be really
small so tiny dude and you just you just
know the [__] out of everyone you know
what I mean you're so sick of everybody
cuz you know them so well like all my
you think that's a good thing though it
helps you really get to know people like
I think it's a great thing but I it's so
weird it's like I it's almost like I had
a premonition that I was going to leave
one day and not know anything about the
world because I just know the same nine
people like my whole freaking life and
then always wanted to just
I just wanted to like meet different of
people like everyone I knew was 7 avist
it was like okay the cool thing about
the private school he went to though it
just felt like um like a massive group
yeah cuz people would just invite each
other for birthday parties and all that
and then when you go to public school
like it's easy to leave people out cuz
it's so massive that's true that's the
part I didn't learn like I didn't
understand how how well I had it where
it was like Wow our community was so
tight-knit everybody looked out for each
other you can't build a community that
big and that close with all the r and
people in the world I wonder how
homeschool kids feel then if they feel
like [__] I just want one dude that must
be rough bro like I could never imagine
myself going through that but find that
most homeschool kids do a lot of
extracurriculars though like throughout
the week yeah but it's not the same when
it's like it's like spotty you know like
you go do this thing and then you do
this thing it's not like you'll spend
like a whole day I see them during
recess or even in passing or even in the
bathroom like it's it's a little bit
different EAS con at least back then it
felt like there was a huge disconnect
between like like if we had homeschooled
kids that started going to school which
we would have some of them they'd be
weird as [__] they're hella weird yeah
and I don't I don't know if they're
still weird today but back then I bet
they are weird bro Society moves fast if
you take two years of your development
time away from socializing how do you
catch up right you take you literally
Miss like a week of math class in school
growing up and like you fall behind
forever like yeah that's why I got to
beat them all up so much to keep up with
give them a nice childhood memory huh
like a sandwich just kidding news
careful Bo is a brand just kidding news
is the man of smart people the people of
just kidding news careful boys they are
very smart just kidding news the number
one podcast in the
[Music]
world